- There's a lot of places
that don't let me perform
simply because I'm black.
That doesn't really get
to me because I'm trying
to show the world that, you know, music is universal,
it can unite us all.
(upbeat music)
My name is Rhyan Lowery, and I'm also known
as El Compa Negro.
El Compa Negro simply
means the black friend.
I sing Regional Musica Mexicana, Banda,
Sierreño, Norteño, Mariachi.
Since I was little, I've
been around Hispanics,
so it actually comes
natural in me, it flows out.
I grew up in the streets of Compton.
I lived in a neighborhood
that was predominantly
black and Mexican.
It's a wonderful thing to
say, you know, ”I came from Compton."
Because they say a lot of
people don't make it out.
I've traveled to a lot of places
and I'm all over TV,
and I can say,
"Hey, I'm from Compton."
A lot of people tell me,
"Hey, you're supposed to be Mexican,
"God just left you in the oven too long."
(laughing)
I know for a fact that
I am African American,
but, yeah, I do feel
like I live that life.
I have lived the ranchero life.
I've had horses, I've had roosters, goats,
eggs, everything.
I know how to saddle up a horse,
get on there, make him
dance and everything.
A lot of people misunderstand and say,
"Hey, you're trying to
be Mexican too much."
I'm like, "Well, there
are American cowboys."
There are people who use boots.
That's what I was taught,
what I've been around.
But, yes, like I said in my song--
(horse neighs)
But like I said in my song,
I have the heart and soul of a Mexican.
I think that that pretty
much is what counts.